i'm just hearing from a very high level
government source telling me that it's
dumb it's done he needed a final posh
push rather but it is
done come back to you just a second rory
your thoughts on that that well
it sounds like it's all okay if you're
hearing it from someone very senior in
the government that it's all over i
think that is very much what we were
expecting and what has been looking
inevitable over the past few hours if it
seemed yesterday that boris johnson
thought he could carry on and get new
people in his top team it's become
incredibly evident this morning with the
departures of more key cabinet ministers
other cabinet ministers making clear
that they won't desert their posts for
national security reasons but urging the
prime minister to go it is game over and
it sounds from what you're saying and
what we're hearing from others in
downing street as if
the prime minister is now preparing for
that and will be
preparing to go
in the coming hours